This might be a terrible idea for a video to do in a hotel room, by yourself,
without the muse that is the inspiration for this video
But that's never stopped me before
oh no
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig if you did not know now you know your life is different now
I was gonna shoot this video last week and I just didn't have time
and right now I'm in New York City and so I'm shooting this video
I literally brought face paint on the plane with me to New York
so now I really have held myself accountable
I just gotta do it
I've been talking myself out of it for the last 20 minutes and I just gotta do it
*sigh* so we're gonna try and do it
Am I already breaking out in hives?
"Anxiety Queen" yeaah! Kelsey Darragh I see you
Okay! Last week Jenna Marbles made a video where she turned herself into her dog, Kermit
I was cracking up, I love it, I thought it was so funny
and she did a genuinely really great job
That day I was like "I wanna do that with Goose!" - my dog if you don't know
I have a dog, she's a murder machine.
She's not with me now, but she has a very expressive face
and I have a very endless desire, if you don't know this by now, to try and paint my face
'cause somehow I think I can do it.
Every time.
Let's accentuate these bones.
Tell me how beautiful this starts to look
Wow. Wow. Wow. That's...I mean...that's beautiful.
Profiles are very different but both of them say,
"Are you okay?"
Okay, give me some black liner, let's f*** this s*** up
Doesn't stop me from trying, apparently
Today I'm genuinely going to try to turn myself into Goose
I have a couple photos but I think I'm gonna try and go off of this photo for the transformation
Also I have makeup on my face already from this morning
I put fake eyelashes on and just don't wanna take 'em off for this
So, I don't think I'm gonna take 'em off for this
Also Jenna followed a video of a professional makeup artist transforming themselves into her dog
so she had at least something to go off of
I have just a photo and extraordinarily blind and dumb ambition
So let's do this
Let me show you this setup that we got goin' on
It's very professional
There's my mirror ("hi!")
Water.
These.
This is a beautiful, moody, New York City windowscape
That's the inspiration.
So I'm assuming we wanna start with, like, the lighter colors and build up to the darker colors
So we're gonna start with white
Here's a brush, and here's white
Good thing this white is already definitely mixed with blue
It's already pretty dirty and muddled, but that's fine because Goose is never completely clean
Once I wash her, she just rolls directly in dirt
It's like a very obvious protest
I know a lot of you are like, "why didn't you just wait to do this at home when you could have Goose right there?"
and my answer to that is,
I don't know
Ooh, wow, look at that
That's...just...a ghost penis exploding on my face
Ohh man
We wanna get that more like, brownish orangeish color
of her fur that she has
Let's do orange and black, makes like that brownish color
Umm, sort of
Okay, just sort of, sort of it
Goose is basically like a jack-o-lantern.
Goose also looks like the dog emoji if you look on your phone
or, prehistoric to phones, she looks like the dog from Duck Hunt
Quite a resume
Mmhmm, really good.
Really, really good stuff.
Blend this stuff a little more.
I don't wanna look like a god damn idiot
Now I wanna create some of the pink jowls that she's got goin' on the sides
so I'm gonna try to do some of that
Not so much a jowl as just a pink line on my face
Cute.
We're trying.
Okay, now we're gonna start moving on to the black.
This is where we get into the full definition and detail of all of this.
She basically is like a Jersey Girl, she's just like
"smokey eye, all damn day"
("Who Let the Dogs Out" plays)
Does this look like a dog or
does this look like a f***ing crazy person?
Spoiler: it's both!
lololol
("Who Let the Dogs Out" plays)
Lots of blending
I think the nose is really gonna be the thing that brings this together
This looks like a weird Cheshire Cat
Okay, we stopped recording because it's been too long.
We're back!
Time for the nose. The nose is really gonna be the thing that changes the game.
*laughs*
("Who Let the Dogs Out" plays)
We're gettin' it, now let's just see if we can do some detail work
Okay! Hold on, how do I--
Let me see if I can get my hair to do relatively what Goose's ears are doing
Oh my god, this is freaking me out from afar
Okay, my hair sort of is doing what Goose's ears are doing, not really, I'm trying
Oh my god, this is, hold on, this is weird, this is weird
THIS IS WEIRD
Okay, ready?
("Who Let the Dogs Out" plays)
I thin  k I did, th-,
I don't like looking at myself now
I don't like, ugh, mmm
There you go, I think I did it as good as I could do for the skill sets which I have instilled in my body
Also, I'm a 32 year old businesswoman who was sent to New York City to speak to advertising executives
about opportunities for them to invest in a
creative comedy show that she does with her best friend on the internet, so...
What a resume!
If you guys liked this video give it a thumbs up!
Let me know in the comments down below what you think I should try to transform myself into next!
Try-nsformers. Maybe that's a good name for this series? Nope? Anyway...
*burps* ugh, yep, that's the bell
I don't know
There's also just a bunch of windows that I'm starin' at, so...
You guys have all seen weirder things in New York City
I saw a man s*** on the side of a building
Next to the place I wanted to get noodles
And it didn't stop me from getting them damn noodles
Okay!